[Music]
the secrets of their success doesn't lie
in any one place but one place to look
is here
I expect energy from everybody the
University of Maryland is a Powerhouse
in America's College production line one
two three
Joshua swarovski's coaching career spans
the Decades of America's growth from
Fall Guys to contenders
of his have played in the past five
World Cups
let's go
there's a competitiveness about the
American athlete a winning mentality a
toughness that is bred through sometimes
across different sports
Club academies have become the
predominant route here to the sports
highest level
but the U.S college system remains a
pathway to the professional game
20 years ago the United States reached
the quarter-finals of the World Cup they
are players on the big stage albeit
forever in the shadow of the women's
team in this country they've won the
World Cup four times
America's women are the sports
superpowers during part of the years
when soccer scholarships attracted the
best female athletes while men chose
more traditional American Sports
whatever the successes and failures of
the past it's all about the game in
Qatar
I will say USA
USI all the way will win the cup it's
coming home it's called soccer's
[Music]
is coming
here they sing soccer is coming home a
Mickey take on England's Anthem having
been given the beautiful game
they're giving a bit back
James Matthews Sky News in Maryland